well good evening at welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight if you've been watching
TV today you know that thousands of
children walked out of school across
America demanding the passage of new gun
control laws as follows the mass
shooting in parkland Florida of course
the walkout is being hailed by a ruling
class as an act of moral bravery but of
course students do not act independently
brave as they may be they can't act
independently they're under the control
of adults in this case by definition
they're in school so when you hear
sixteen-year-old scream hey NRA how many
people did you kill today
you can guess about whether they know
what they're saying or whether they
really believe it some of them do but
you can be certain adults are behind it
and they are today's events were
organized by the women's March with the
support of dozens of other groups from
Michael Bloomberg's gun lobby to Planned
Parenthood celebrities journalists
political elites across the country
cheered them on the TV channel
Nickelodeon went dark for 17 minutes to
show support for quote kids leading the
way in New York City a student died in
was joined by the governor of the state
Andrew Cuomo in Baltimore that city
spent more than a hundred grand in
taxpayer money to transport students to
anti-gun rallies this in a city with one
of the highest murder rates in the
nation
a city that cannot afford trash cans or
streetlights meanwhile Alexandria
Virginia 65 students walked out of an
elementary school as if kids under 10
can go anywhere by themselves now what
do you like the kids are like what
they're saying and you may but you
should be opposed to this because kids
should not be used to advance political
agendas anyone's why because they're
children they're not old enough to have
the perspective that adults do that's
why we don't let them vote or drink or
if today's protesters have their way by
guns and so it's wrong to exploit them
which by the way is exactly what is
being done to them today what the left
is doing and has always done from mouths
red guards to right now the ANC in South
Africa used kids as political props in
the 80s their cause was obviously
morally defensible causes usually are
morally defensible but in the process an
entire generation of kids learn to
believe that activism is more important
than learning and a lot of them on
credit now they were exploited and
they're being exploited here no matter
what they chant remember that the enemy
of the adults behind this isn't the NRA
it's anyone who opposes their broader
agenda that's mostly people who have no
power
at all so the message from our elites is
really simple stand against us and
you're against children and therefore
you're a monster and if you're a monster
you deserve to be destroyed it's a kind
of moral blackmail igor Volsky is
director of guns down America he joins
the st. you Gore thanks come on thanks
for having me so my complaint is not
that people disagree with me on the
Second Amendment I think that's totally
legitimate and I think it's fair to have
a debate I probably agree with you
actually but well maybe you do my first
problem is the use of children to make a
political point so would you for example
I know you supported what happened today
have a problem if these kids were being
driven by their teachers and buses to a
to an NRA rally or if they were rallying
against transgender bathrooms the march
for biology how would you feel about
that well you know what I'd love to see
I love to see students who are out there
engaging in the democratic process
students who are doing really what
teachers want them to do what teachers
teach them to do and that is take part
in critical thinking find something they
believe in
and fight for it I mean you saw the
students in a cynical thinking here
there's no but you didn't answer my
question which is if they were being
taken to pro-life marches or anti-gay
marriage marches or something you
disagree with your premise I don't think
about how would you feel what would you
say that's totally cool that that's my
question a hypothetical question oh yes
do I think students should be taken
against their will somewhere to know
yeah I just I don't care what it is if
teachers were abetting a march of
teachers across country or sending kids
let me help you get to a March that
represented something that you found
morally repugnant would you be
supportive on principle would you say
this is them engaging the democratic
process for guns I mean if your premise
is should students be taken somewhere by
teachers where they don't want to go
I agree would you be fighting if you
want to do this and you heard the
students after the shooting you heard
what the students said they believed
this in their gut and the reason is
tucker is because they've experienced
these bullets they've heard these months
they buried their classmates that's why
they're doing nobody's forcing them
and I'm not saying that kids who are
under the care of a teacher who has
control of their grades in life are not
free agents they can't act fully
independently as you and I can because
they are under the control of an
authority figure this is really simple
this is why teachers aren't allowed to
have sex with students because they're
in power and the kids aren't so why are
teachers allowed to direct kids toward a
political ideology it's really simple
because this teachers are not directing
students to anything this is student-led
this is the power of this movement of
this moment is that we're now in a
situation where students are saying
enough is enough from the lawmakers who
don't want to change the gun laws enough
is enough from the NRA who wants to I
mean if I could just make an obvious
almost technical point which is that
kids can't vote kids of the age of most
of these students 16 year olds can't
vote so they're actually not in the
democratic process and we've agreed that
they shouldn't be in the democratic
process we've agreed that until they can
make rational decisions they can't vote
and by the way you don't want them to
buy guns so if they're too young to buy
guns why should they be making my gun
laws but you know once the NRA the NRA
specifically looked at the inner well
I'm asking you what you think and why
should people who don't have the right
to buy guns have the right to make my
gun laws it's a simple question once I
mean they're not they're not making your
gun laws along yeah and as citizens in
this country they're allowed to lose
their children and they're not of 18
they're Americans look but they don't
have the full rights of citizenship
because they're not adults they can't
drink alcohol they a lot of them can't
drive cars you don't want em to buy guns
and they can't vote I mean is there a
difference between an adult and a child
I mean of course okay then why would
knowledge that thing
well of course my point is they've been
placed in this situation where their
lives are in danger in American schools
and the reason is is because of
decisions a holdup that lawmakers made
and B because of the agenda of the end
that wants to put even more than their
classroom today I think it's okay for
them and I think it's in fact noble for
them get it because you like going out
if one of their teachers some scary
alt-right person was taking them to a
Mylo rally you would freak out as you
know and you know just admit it
and let's just be honest with each other
fifty thousand kids going to a mile away
innopolis rally right now taken by their
teachers from Fort Worth you would say
this is the end of America evidence
aren't doing this because going to milah
rallies because that's not what they
believe Chuck err you what progress if
adults believe Tucker you had students
bury their friends I agree you had
students lose friends I've seen what
you're dismissing I'm not in anywhere
distances what saying the adults told
them watch what you're doing is engaging
in the classic moral blackmail
techniques of the left which is rather
than make a rational case you point to
children and say if you oppose what I
believe you're against no no here's a
rational case let me ask you a rational
question you have sent a number of
tweets out recently saying the cops are
racist they kill a disproportionately
high number of African Americans yep
racism plus police brutality plus guns
equals alton sterling Flender bullets of
you are you know if you believe that the
police have a problem with racist
violence why do you want the police to
be the only people to have guns it's
simple question well I don't want the
police to be the only people to have
guns I want I want to move us to a
country with we where we have fewer guns
and where we don't have a soul weapon
and where we don't have assault weapons
that can kill largely the cops have what
we need the cops that you've described
as racist would they have assault
weapons Tucker what he says I am arguing
that racism plays a role in the
disproportionate murder of young black
men and I don't know why you're not why
you're so trusting of police you say are
killing people out of
no that's not I'm saying look I want to
have it I don't have a sweater I'm
trying to have a serious conversation
I'm just missing the children you're
laughing at the huge I have not just
missing the children you're dismissing
these children of course I'm not I think
you are you want to stop Democrats
without of their way to pander during
today's protests watch we need laws not
nice thoughts and prayers the NRA has
made me public enemy number one and I'm
proud of it are you gonna vote out of
office the people who take the gun lobby
money and put yourself in the NRA has
held Congress hostage for years now
these young people have shown up to
spring us free we need a vote now we
need
now Dan Medina was a former Secret
Service agent and a contributor to NRA
TV and he joins us tonight hey Dan so
what do you make of this what do you
this make of this March well a couple
things are going on here and your prior
guests did it Nancy Pelosi just did it a
number of those politicians taking
advantage of those kids at a rally I
thought was designed to reduce targeted
school violence not to pass legislative
items on the Democratic Enda but you
know shame on us for bringing it up
dunker we're the ones who are dismissing
the kids according to the left but he
did two things your prior guest which is
interesting here first he did the appeal
to emotion where they talk about emotion
as if emotion is reason in this case of
course we all feel horrible but what
happened in parkland that the points
stipulated there's there's no dispute
there but what he does is he confuses
the emotion surrounding me a situation
with reason and reasonable measures that
were going forward would reduce school
violence but he did something else that
I found particularly disturbing and they
do it to the Liberals do this all the
time they do this utopian fallacy thing
where they say things that are clearly
nonsensical designed to make you look
foolish what they do is they say things
like what we all want fewer guns in
schools of course we do but you don't
get to pick that the darn bad guy does
Tucker the bad guy walks you think the
bad guy walks in there to school and he
goes oh listen there's a sign up that
says we want fewer guns in schools let
me turn around we don't live in Utopia
we don't live in a perfect world and
it's really infuriating having a debate
with people who constantly engage in
these silly tactics never want to get
anything reasonable done yeah and they
do this strictly to make you look silly
so how would you feel if your child's
teacher were proselytizing about a very
specific political view and then took
him out of school put him on a bus and
brought him to a political rally
wouldn't you have a right to be outraged
since that's not why you're sending him
to school I arrange I'd be pretty pissed
Tucker I send my kids to school to learn
you know reading anything at arithmetic
I don't expect political indoctrination
now I don't listen if a teacher has a
political opinion and it's happened to
me before I've lived in a couple liberal
states I unlike
a lot of liberals encourage my daughters
to go back to school and make their case
and make it in a reasonable fashion and
you know what if the teacher gives them
a bad grade because of it we can go
fight that fight but that's what
reasonable people do they don't
encourage kids to walk out of school
during the middle of the day I mean you
know what kept occurring to me today
what happened god forbid one of these
kids walking out of school was hit by a
car or something like that I don't send
my kids to school to engage in a
political protest come on now and you
ought to pull your kids out immediately
if they are exploited in the way these
kids are being in my opinion you gotta
pull them out anyway
it's a joke dan thank you great to see
you